i'd be remiss as a huge office fan to to
not bring it up real quick that's what
she said
it's been a wild year and certainly the
friends reunion brought people so much
joy and was such a huge success and it
got me thinking
are you having any conversations about
maybe doing something like that to
celebrate the office
i haven't personally had that
conversation but i think it's a lovely
idea i think it's a wonderful idea and i
think what's also why it's also a great
idea is that the office seems to me has
been uh a real comfort to people during
this last 18 months people seem to have
watched it
religiously it seems you know from what
i understand the numbers are through the
roof you know people have just
re-re-watched it and again i think it's
partly because it's ultimately a story
about sort of community and that they
are sort of unlikely friends in the end
and they're friends that only know each
other through sort of the place that
they work but i think there's something
nice particularly as we've been so
divided from each other for the last 18
months being able to watch a show where
people are sort of in a room together i
think it's been a weird kind of comfort
so um no i think the idea of reading is
a lovely idea you know i i know you were
an executive producer on the american
office is there any sort of a status or
anything that you can share about
if you wanted this project to come to
life what it would look like
i always hear kind of rumors about you
know
that there's talk of someone wanting to
bring it back um
there's nothing certain i can that i can
give you an exclusive one that i've i've
heard i just i'm always hearing those
stories but they're always from
different people and they kind of bubble
up and disappear again so i don't know i
think sometimes
well i think it can be dangerous to
revisit things can't it you know that
sometimes the sort of magic it's hard to
make the magic happen again
the second time round so i don't know if
it's necessarily a good idea i think
sometimes people want that and maybe
it's not as it's not such a good idea
after all i don't know but certainly i'm
not you know i love all those actors i
love the world i would happily watch 10
more seasons so um
you know if it does happen i'll be a fan
like everybody else
what will it take to get karel on board
i don't know i don't know
maybe um
maybe he just does it maybe it's just
animated like i am in this movie maybe
just does it from home and they just cgi
him and he doesn't have to show up maybe
all the action maybe that would work for
all the actors or maybe we do like a
muppet a muppet babies version where
it's just the voices of the cast but
they're all sort of them
as kids
that's a life
a boy called christmas what a holiday
delight and bonus points it's releasing
on your birthday
it is releasing on my birthday which
unfortunately also clashes with
thanksgiving
generally and so everyone goes home to
see their family so whenever whenever
i'm in america and it's my birthday
there's no one around to to celebrate
with but no but in this case this is in
this year i'm i'm in the uk we'll
celebrate thanksgiving so actually
there'll be a few people to raise a
glass but um no i love the fact that
it's sort of a christmas film that's one
of the things which which was so
appealing to me because i've got young
nieces and nephews and and i can't wait
for them to come over this christmas and
sort of see it and normally i make quite
adult things you know and i like the
stuff i make myself you know
quite edgy and it's not really suitable
for younguns so i'm pleased that the
family will be able to enjoy it together
you ready old friend born ready
you can talk and i can fly as well no
just kidding no mice can fly that would
be absurd you have your pick of what you
want to do in hollywood and for you to
sign up and do a movie like a boy called
christmas is it to get those brownie
points with nieces and nephews or what
is it about this project that you were
like i must do it
it's part of that but it's also the the
idea of the origin story of santa claus
felt like a story that i must have seen
before and actually when i stopped to
think about it i couldn't really think
of that before it seemed like what a
great classic
tale plus i get to play a talking mouse
um you know and really stretch myself i
mean you know listen i'm six foot seven
and i'm playing a mouse guy so you might
want to get the uh the academy award
people to to really pay attention here
because that's not an easy uh role for
someone my height to get into the
mindset of no let's definitely get the
fyc campaign going i'm gonna be honest
kid i did not see this one working out
for us
what is this this is a christmas party
it's cake city
no idea what this christmas thing is but
i love it are you someone who enjoys
going to a sound booth and doing this
project you know in your pajamas or did
you miss being on set and interacting
with humans
i love going to a sound booth
and being in my pajamas exactly like i
am now i mean i appear like i'm wearing
a suit but i'm just in my boxers and
slippers underneath here please come on
i'm not getting dressed up i'm in my own
house when you're on set although it's
fun it's great like you say the
camaraderie there's a lot of pressure
because it's so expensive and so you
don't generally get as much time to just
be playful and improvised and um and
whereas when you're doing a voiceover
you're in the booth and you've got a lot
more time and so gil was the director
was very encouraging and let me be
playful and ad-lib and allow me to try
and make a connection with henry the
lead who i'm sort of friends with but
who i never met until the premiere the
other night
um and so
that's what's sort of fun that's that's
its own interesting challenge and
very enjoyable like i said because you
get so much creative freedom you said
you're at home in the uk i'm curious on
a scale of one to mariah carey where
does your holiday spirit rank
i am very i'm a very a big christmas fan
i don't i'm sort of there i'm pushing
the mariah levels of
christmas spirit i
i like the sentiment of it i like the
christmas tunes including mariah's
i would quite happily put them on in
june i love those tunes um i know i'm
sure if you're working in a department
store it must be unbearable but i love
hearing them on the radio i like seeing
the lights up the christmas decorations
you know i live in london uh when i'm in
the uk and you know that gets so magical
at christmas time with the lights and
the kind of it feels very dickensian and
kind of victorian and and um so i i get
fully in the christmas spirit um i i
really i really enjoy it it's just one
day a year what should we call it
nicholas and mika the talking mouse day
any other ideas
[Music]